[Music]
you've been very successful you've
carved out this niche for you you've
really made yourself king of the nerds
and all things nerd which i think is
fantastic it is there's no leader i am a
servant in the nerd army that is merely
that is merely what i am that's a scary
army uh
but you recently did something that
seems very unnerd-like is that not true
a hundred percent okay what was it all
right so uh the dodgers do this thing
called star wars night where everyone
comes straight so far so pretty nerdy
like let's hear about your cool
unnerving that was my it starts with
stairwell that's right
and r2 was the umpire and the
stormtroopers are catchers so uh we
there's a star wars night it doesn't
start was nicer stadium so they said you
we'd love you throughout the first pitch
and i was like
sports you know like that was my
there's a reason my my girlfriend says
there's a reason your podcast is called
the nerdist not the sportest like i'm
not sporty i'm not a sports guy and so i
call my mom who is like the biggest
sports person like she calls in sports
talk radio shows and yells swears at
them like she's that kind of she knows
all the facts and all those other stuff
knows everything so i go look i'm gonna
throw out the first pitch at the dodger
game then there was a scream for about a
minute and then she got into like stage
mom mode where she was like all right
you got to go down to practice and you
got to get up on the mound and it's
higher than you think don't throw down
to the catcher you're going to want to
throw high and then it'll go down and
i'm like take it easy mommy lasorda like
it got crazy right and and so i i
followed her advice and i did not i i
did it you practiced i did and uh what
happened you got up on the mound and you
you you threw the pitch yes and uh did
you you you made it i'm happy to report
the ball went high and wide which is way
better than in the dirt right uh and i
got so excited that i didn't wing the
ball into the dirt that i ran from the
mound and
jumped onto the catcher and just wrapped
my limbs around him right do we have a
picture i think we got a picture i'm
afraid we might yeah
that's how excited i was i like that
there's a big
big star wars logo behind you of course
there was not at all worried about you
might hurt this guy he's a multi-million
dollar athlete i'm just like i need to
hold someone because i was so and it
took them six hours to pry you off yeah
i just stayed on him for the whole game
i'm like let's do it
i like that you wore a mitt when you
were just gonna throw yeah
i know what did you think he was going
to like surprise you by throwing it back
andy i don't i don't know sports i might
have brought a hockey stick like i don't
know how this stuff works i'm just glad
i got the right one for anything to
butcher exactly now tell us
we must ask you dark knight rises yes uh
the special screening the the premiere i
guess is tonight yeah this is when and
it's uh yeah i think because this show
starts at 11 and it's now oh come on
yes it's really like just 20 minutes
away this show is going to be yeah i
know it's exciting so um you anything
you can tell have you seen dark knight
rise i did the company that that made
dark night legendary bought nerdist like
i so they acquired us they own you they
own me now and happily so so i got to
see a screening earlier this week and
it's amazing i don't give anything away
i think it's weird that alfred hangs
himself three minutes into the movie but
you guys will see it it's gonna be great
um
and then uh an awesome superman cameo
but again you guys you'll love it uh
don't i i would still go see it yeah i
would still go see it so it's a lot of
people would hate you
so mad if you gave stuff away